okay one i guess black black can pretty  much pre-move king f8  he said a5 not a5 he also said king f1 i  think  rapper and nakamura are done all smiles  there as they shake hands game ends  peacefully  two nights on the board  that's the left over  icaru all dressed up today no jeans no  more dress code issues  do you see that debate that  he i only saw his tweet i didn't see it  on cameras watching but apparently he  was watching he was wearing jeans during  the third round and then he got a  complaint from feeder that he violated  the dress code and he complained that  fida had not enforced his violations  of the dress code  previously  what do we think about dress codes  i mean as long as a player isn't  i don't know as long as they're  relatively well-dressed i didn't see the